Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Cameron Cutters. I want to welcome you to our site if this is due to you
Please take time and look around. We really I really see our major ministry is to educate and to teach that I mean that's really I believe
One purpose that God has for me is to take complex
Ideas and data that's out there and break it down it to bite-size pieces for people to be able to
Be blessed in a lot of ways and help their body heal
That's why we created all our courses our flagship courses the stop-fighting cancer course and our flagship
Thing that we do is take care of people that have cancer now
I have a lot of knowledge and live disease a wrote several books on live disease a book on detoxification
genetics and
Years ago I wrote a book on autoimmune disease and we just put up a autoimmune course, but really
God has put me here to help people with cancer and help people with frequency healing with the right
It's probably why you're on this site in the first place is because you were searching for cancer or searching for right
Technology and you came across what we do and you know, that's why most people seek us out
I wrote a book a number of years ago. This is the third edition. It was we we gave it away as a complete free download for a long time
But now it's over 600 pages and it was on the Amazon best seller lists for health and healing section for a time
We've literally had a hundred thousand downloads of this book over the years. It's a great book
I you know, I challenge you if that's the only thing that you can do
To help to learn to start to understand how you could heal naturally
With cancer diagnosis really get that and start digging through it
There's just loads of information that you could help yourself from the very beginning
Now most people come on board with us
Remember we're not healing. We're not healers. God's your healer, but I have your coach
And most people want that individual coaching from me that is available through what we call our comprehensive package
So our comprehensive package includes a private access to all
Zoom calls we do weekly zoom calls right now with me
People can send in their questions on the private members site
You're not seeing that this is our public site
But that's just loaded full of information for people to use
But the nice thing about that site is you have access to me
So you have access to the zoom calls you have access to make appointments with me
You have access to all different protocols that aren't anywhere else
You have access to all our courses all our blogs all our videos and a whole whole lot more
But our comprehensive package has that and
Ability to make those individual appointments with me and and talk to me on a weekly basis with the zoom call
But it also comes with a programmed right for she know this is my programming. I've been doing right technology since the late 90s
So this is my programming specifically for what you have going on
So that's a key thing. That's the number one reason like I said that people really seek us out
They're looking for another addition to what they're doing for their disease
That can help them
It's not at either or you know, it's a addition to what else they could do to help their body heal
We also get full genetic work up so we do a full genetic work up on a person and give
Recommendations and tweak their recommendations that we did for the initial cheek swab test
And our initial recommendation once we get that genetic information back so
This kind of lays out our comprehensive package. You get all that private membership
You get the initial cheek swab testing that I personally do. I give you a binder with
So you could easily access that and we give you an email or what to be doing and following and then you can talk to me on a weekly basis
Submit your questions on a weekly basis and make appointments as necessary as well
talked about the complete members only website and
All the access to all my other videos and everything that I've created over the years
It's a great package. The website is much more complete than this public website and you'll have a lot more knowledge to go through
And personalize help from everybody at our office. You also get that program drive
It comes with the F122 generator a crystal hammer bulb. I am pro if everything you really need to get started and get going
You really don't need anything else
From what we give you
Give you the laptop. We give you everything with the program out of the key is the program
You have to have a right machine that is going to be powerful enough to penetrate your body to actually affect your cells
But if you're running the wrong frequencies, it's not going to do anything for you
This is what the right machine looks like you also get our frequency healing course with it
So you have complete access to be able to know how to use the right for the rest of your family members too
So everybody can be blessed from it
Then I spoke about the truth the complete genetic workup that also comes with the region's course
More information that you can really go through. It's really
Packed full of data
We're here to bless you. We're here to take care of you
I know you need somebody to hold your hand. That's what the comprehensive package is all about
It's really a lot of hand holding you'll call us any time talk to us any time. We're here for you
That's what makes us different and
We know that regardless of what you choose to do with us
We want you to know that we're a ministry whether you start with our courses
Or you just start by reading our website or downloading my book
Just start somewhere don't give up don't let anybody steal your hope away
Know that we're praying for you always and I know that God is on your side. Thanks so much